حياكم الله فازت اسرائيل بمنصب نائب رئيس
اللجنه الرابعه في الجمعيه العامه للامم
المتحده وهي اللجنه السياسيه المعنيه
بانهاء الاستعمار وبقضايا اللاجئين
استنكرت المجموعه العربيه بشده ترشيح
وانتخاب دوله محتله مثل اسرائيل لهذا
المنصب نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش في
محوره ما هي خلفيات انتخاب اسرائيل نائبا
لرئيس لجنه امميه مختصه
بمناهضته التداعيات السياسيه لتولي
اسرائيل هذا
المنصب خبت اسرائيل اذا نائبا لرئيس
اللجنه الامميه الرابعه المعنيه
بمناهضته على
74 صوتا اي ما يعادل
38% من اصوات المجتمع الدولي وقد سبق
لاسرائيل ان تقلدت مناصب في لجان امميه
اخرى الا ان المنصب الحالي هو الاخطر
باعتبار اسرائيل دوله محتله باعتراف الامم
المتحده مفارقه ام انهيار اخلاقي للامم
المتحده وقد قامت على منظومه اخلاقيه تشكل
عصب وجودها واساس شرعيتها سؤال يثيره
انتخاب اسرائيل لمنصب احد نواب اللجنه
الرابعه للجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده
وتلك لجنه تعنى بانهاء الاستعمار وقضيه
اللاجئين الفلسطينيين اضافه الى ما تسمى
مسائل سياسيه خاصه من مثل حقوق الانسان
وحفظ السلام ومكافحه الالغام رشحت اسرائيل
من المجموعه الاقليميه لغرب اوروبا التي
تراسها بريطانيا وتضم دولا من خارج اوروبا
مثل تركيا واسرائيل ونيوزيلندا ووفقا
للاجراء المتبع في الجمعيه العامه فان
اختيار رؤساء اللجان ونوابهم يتم بالتزكيه
بمجرد ترشيحهم لكن قطر الرئيسه الدوريه
للمجموعه العربيه طلبت عرض ترشيح اسرائيل
على التصويت للتعبير عن رفضه
ولنزيد
بالتصويت فازت اسرائيل بالمنصب ب 74 صوتا
اي نحو
38% من الاسره الدوليه نتيجه لا تعكس نصرا
لاسرائيل كما قال مندوب عربي بل هزيمه
للامم المتحده نفسها فالدوله المنتخبه هي
اخر دوله استعماريه في التاريخ المعاصر
وهي باعتراف المنظمه الدوليه دوله احتلال
فكيف يستقيم ان تكون كذلك مع انتخابها في
في لجنه تقوم على انهاء الاستعمار ذلك هو
الانهيار الاخلاقي كما سرعت الخارجيه
الفلسطينيه الى التعليق بينما اعتبر بعض
اخر الامر برمته كوميديا السوداء تبكي
وتضحك في ذات الوقت تمتد حروب اسرائيل في
المنطقه على مدى 66 عاما من حرب عام 48
الى الحرب على غزه وخلال هذه الحروب اصدرت
الامم المتحده قرارات نص على ضروره قيام
اسرائيل بانهاء احتلالها اي استعمارها
للاراضي العربيه لينتهي الامر بتسلل
اسرائيل من ثقوب اليات عمل المنظمه
الدوليه الى منصب في لجنتها الخاصه بانهاء
الاستعمار ما كان مقرر الامم المتحده
لحقوق الانسان ريتشارد فولك او القاضي
ريتشارد جولدستون ليتخيل هذا وهما مسلحان
بشرعه الامم المتحده ينددان في تقاريره ما
بما ترتكب اسرائيل من انتهاكات للقانون
الدولي والانساني في فلسطين وجثث
شعبها لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا في
الاستديو الدكتور فواز جرجس استاذ
العلاقات الدوليه ومدير مركز الشرق الاوسط
بجامعه لندن ومن مقر الامم المتحده في
نيويورك معنا الدكتور عبد الحميد الصيام
المتحدث السابق والخبير في شؤون الامم
المتحده من رام الله معنا الدكتور مصطفى
البرغوثي الامين العام للمبادره الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه ابدا معك دكتور عبد الحميد
الصيام ربما من المفيد اولا ان نفهم ما هي
الاليات التي مكنت اسرائيل من الوصول الى
منصب بهذا بهذه
الحساسيه نعم في البدايه اود ان اوضح ان
اسرائيل لغايه عام 2000 لم تكن ضمن اي
مجموعه جغرافيه هي الدوله الوحيده في
العالم التي لم تكن مشموله ضمن المجموعات
الجغرافيه ف ف مجموعه اسيا حيث توجد
اسرائيل لم تكن تقبل بها واخذ قرار مؤقت
من مجموعه دول اوروبا الغربيه ودول اخرى
لضمها مؤقتا من اجل تسهيل عمل اللجان
المهم ان الاتحاد
الاوروبي تبنى اسرائيل ووضعها في قمه
اولوياته واعاده تاهيلها وقد انتخبت ثلاث
مرات كنائب لرئيس الجمعيه العامه انتخبت
لاول مره عام 2000 اي بعد دخول
مباشره مجموعه الدول الاوروبا الغربيه ثم
انتخبت عام 2009 ثم انتخبت مره اخرى عام
2012 وهذه هي المره الاولى التي تنتخب في
اللجنه الرابعه اللجنه الرابعه اهميتها
انها معنيه بتصفيه الاستعمار هي التي تشرف
على تنفيذ الاتفاق الدولي لانهاء مناط قبح
اهم هذه اللنه همنا اذا سمحت لي دكتور
يعني يهمن ان نعرف كيف وصلت لان تصبح
المرشح الوحيد لهذا المم المنصف المنصب
مهم جدا ان نفهم هذه الاليه
يعني نعم الترشيح يكون ضمن المجموعات
الجغرافيه لا احد يتدخل في ذلك تجتمع
المجموعات الجغرافيه مثلا مجموعه اسيا
اجتمعت ورشحت ممثل نيبال ليكون رئيس هذه
اللجنه يعرض الترشيح على الجمعيه على على
الامانه العامه جميع على الجمعيه العامه
بكل اعضائها ويتم التصويت عليه عاده بال
الاجماع دون عد الاصوات لاول مره المجموعه
الاوروبيه اتفقت فيما بينها ان ترشح
اسرائيل طبعا لا احد يجبر المجموعه
الاوروبيه ان لا تعمل ذلك لان اسرائيل
جزءا منها لكن المفاجاه للعرب ولحل فائه
وللمجموعات الاستعمار ياتي مرشح المجموعه
الاوروبيه والذي من حقهم ان يكون لهم نائب
رئيس هذا حق للمجموعه الاوروبيه كما ان
هناك نائب رئيس من المجموعه الافريقيه
ورئيس اللجنه من المجموعه الاسيويه وهكذا
فالمجموع الاوروبيه رشحت اسرائيل اذا ليس
لاحد اي خيار فيما رشح لكن المفاجاه انهم
يرشحوا اسرائيل لانها اهانه للمجموعه
العربيه وخاصه في هذا الوقت بالذات التي
تمارس فيه اسرائيل كافه الانتهاكات
الدوليه بعد خطف الثلاث مستوطنين يوم
الجمعه
الماض يعني هل هناك تعاطف مع اسرائيل في
هذه المرحله مثلا خصوصا دعت الى هذا
ترشيح نعم يعني هناك نوع من التعاطف ظهر
بعد خطف الثلاث مستوطنين ثم حكومه حكومه
التوافق الوطني واعاده تاهيل حركه حماس ثم
لان هناك وقف الان لعمليه المفاوضات يعني
هناك مجموعات اوروبيه طيب استراليا مثلا
كنوع من هذا التعاطف وهي جزء من هذه
المجموعه عندما اقرت ان القدس الشرقيه
ليست محت
يعني المجموعه الاوروبيه هي التي تتبنى
اسرائيل وتسوقها داخل الامم المتحده دكتور
فواز جرجس ربما مما ذكره الدكتور عبد
الحميد الصيام ان منذ
دخول اسرائيل عام 2000 الى هذه المجموعه
وهي في الواقع ترشحت لاكثر من لجنه وفازت
بها هذه اللجنه تحديدا اللجنه الرابعه
لمناهضه الاستعمار ما حساسيه وجود اسرائيل
في منصب قيادي فيها اولا الحقيقه توضيح
بسيط هذا القرار هو ليس اهانه للعرب
والمسلمين هذا القرار هو اهانه للاسره
الدوليه هو اهانه للمصداقيه الاخلاقيه
للامم المتحده للمؤسسات الدوليه انت تنتخب
دوله تحتل ارضا وشعبا انت تنتخب دوله تقوم
باسوا الممارسات ضد الانسانيه انت تنتخب
دوله مهمتها تصفيه الاستعمار ومن ثم تبني
المستوطنات وتبتلع الارض الفلسطينيه هذه
النقطه الاولى هذه النقطه مهمه جدا جدا
كيف يمكن ان تطلبي من العالم ان يحترم
قرارات مجلس الامن والامم المتحده ومن ثم
تنتخب دوله هي الحقيقه مسؤوله عن تصفيه
الاستعمار تناقض ليس فقط ا تناق وما موقف
القانون الدولي من هذا التناقض انا انا لا
اتكلم كعربي انا كانسان كقضيه انسانيه
امميه تمثل حقيقه شرخا كبيرا في هذه
المؤسسه الانسانيه والدوليه قانونيا
ارجعون السؤال الحقيقه نحن نتكلم هناك سي
سياسه دوليه هناك علاقات دوليه هناك
موازين قوى وهناك قضايا ترشيح منذ
2000 للمشاهد العربي منذ حوالي اكثر من 10
سنوات الدول الاوروبيه والولايات المتحده
تحاول جاهده تاهيل اسرائيل محاول تحاول
جاهده التركيز على الامم المتحده ان الامم
المتحده لديها سياسه عدائيه ضد اسرائيل ان
الامم المتحده منحازه الى العرب والمسلمين
والفلسطينيين ومن ثم يعني ممنهج نقد ممنهج
وهجوم ممنهج على الامم المتحده من اجل
حقيقه دمج اسرائيل في الامم المتحده
والمؤسسات الدوليه نقطه اخرى اخيره قبل ان
نهي هذه المداخله في الواقع الحقيقه تتخوف
اسرائيل وا اصدقاء اسرائيل الدول الغربيه
من ان من عزله اسرائيل ال في ال المؤسسات
الدوليه لان هذه العزله يمكن ان يكون لها
تداعيات قانونيه واخلاقيه ومصيره على
مستقبل اسرائيل ومن هنا
هذا القرار لا يمكن عزله عن الخلفيه
السياسيه الممنهجه من قبل الدول الاوروبيه
والولايات المتحده من اجل حقيقه دفع
واجبار بطريقه يعني الامم المتحده من خلال
انه قررت تلك الدول الاوروبيه ومن هنا
خلفيه لهذا القرار واعتقد ان هذا القرار
سوف يكون له تداعيات خطيره على مصداقيه
الامم المتحده وكيف ينظر الى الامم
المتحده في الاسره الدوليه وليس فقط اذاء
العالم العربي والاسلام ني الاساسي بهذا
القرار هو الفلسطينيين انفسهم دكتور مصطفى
البرغوثي هل
فجئته طبعا هذا امر مفاجئ ويشكل فضيحه
فضيحه كبرى للامم المتحده فضيحه كبرى
للدول الاوروبيه التي تحتضن اسرائيل وتدعي
انها تريد ان تدعم انهاء الاحتلال واقامه
سلام في هذه المنطقه ثم تتبنى اسرائيل
وتضعها في هذا هذا الموقع المشين وا الذي
يمثل ازدواجيه في المواقف وايضا يمثل موقف
لا يمكن تبريره لا من الناحيه القانونيه
ولا السياسيه ولا من الناحيه الاخلاقيه
لانه اسرائيل كيان استعماري بدا كاستعمال
ومستمر كا استعمار ويعلن خططه لان يبقى
استعمار من خلال المستوطنات التي يزيد
عددها عن 120 مستوطنه و 650,000 مستعمر
مستوطن غير شرعي وغير قانوني في كل
القوانين الدوليه ما فيها قرار محكمه
الجنايات الدوليه بل اكثر من ذلك اسرائيل
صاحبه الاحتلال الاطول في تاريخ البشريه
الحديث الذي زاد عن 47 عام وهي صاحبه
الجريمه الاكبر التي تسببت باكبر عدد من
اللاجئين وهي نكبه عام 48 وما قامت به من
تطهير عرقي في فلسطين واكثر من ذلك هي
التي تمارس الان احتلالا تحول الى نظام
ابارتيد وفصل عنصري هو الاسوا في تاريخ
البشريه شو لازم اكثر يكون في السجل حتى
لا يسمح لدوله ان تتولى مثل هذا المنصب
وهذا يشكل برايي فعلا اهانه للقانون
الدولي ويطرح سؤال كبير عن مواقف بعض
الدول الاوروبيه وخاصه بريطانيا التي تبنت
هذا الترشيح بالمناسبه داخل المجموعه
الاوروبيه وهذا يتطلب موقف حازم تجاهه
وانا اعتقد انه مع كل لحظه تمر وخاصه الان
واسرائيل تجتاح قواتها الان اسرائيل تمارس
استعمار بغيض في هذه اللحظه تجتاح قواتها
المناطق الفلسطينيه
تعيث فسادا تعتقل المئات هناك اكثر من
5000 بل حوالي 6000 اسير الان في السجون
الاسرائيليه والان اسرائيل تمارس اضطهادا
بشعا في كل مدينه وقريه
فلسطينيه نتحدث قبل قليل كنا نشاهد على
الشاشه يعني اشتباكات في الخليل وما يجري
في الخليل طبعا هذا يعود دعني اعود اليك
دكتور عبد الحميد الصيام يعني انت ذكرت
يعني وايضا دكتور فواز جرجس ان هناك يعني
تمهيد في الواقع لهذه الخ خطوه اكثر من
لجنه دخلت فيها اسرائيل منذ عام 2000 ولكن
لننظر الى الموقف الدول العربيه هنا فقط
اريد ان يعني اقرا بعض ما جاء في البيان
الذي اصدرته يقول يبقى لدعوتنا الى
التصويت اليوم معنى مهم وهو تسجيل رفض
رفضنا القاطع لترشيح اسرائيل ونزع صفه
الاجماع من النتيجه يعني السؤال يعني نزع
صفه الاجماع ما قيمته الان هل هذا اقصى ما
كان يمكن ان تفعله المجموعه العربيه
يعني اعتقد ان الدول العربيه لم تكن مجهزه
لانفس للتعامل مع مثل هذا المشروع مشروع
القرار الذي قدمته بريطانيا لكن استخدمت
رئيسه المجموعه العربيه الممثله الدائمه
لقطر البند 1013 من قانون عمل الجمعيه
العامه لتحويل
التصويتي اكيشن اي القبول عام دون عد
الاصوات الى التصويت السري وهو
ما والدول الغربيه ان يمنعوا ذلك لكنهم
اصروا عليه
وا 70 دوله صوتت لصالح هذا القرار و68
دوله امتنعت عن التصويت او كتبت امتناع
وهناك
15 صوتا لم تحسب لانها كتب فيها اشياء
مذله لاسرائيل بعضها يعني لذلك لم تحظى
على كما قلت اكثر من 38% ل لكن المشكله
انها في هذه اللجنه المشكله انها يعني لو
انتخبت اسرائيل في لجنه مثلا الم
الميزانيه اللجنه الخامسه او في اللجنه
الاقتصاديه اللجنه الثالثه الثانيه او في
اللجنه حتى القانونيه اللجنه يعني يمكن ان
يفهم او او يغضي الطرب ان ت في هذه اللجنه
كما قالت كما قال مندوب السعوديه هي ليس
فشلا نجاحا لاسرائيل بل هو فشل للامم
المتحده وكما قالت مندوبه قطر في الاجتماع
قالت وليقف مندوب اسرائيل الان ويعلن انه
ضد الاحتلال وانه سيقف ضد احتلال اسرائيل
للاراضي الفلسطين ويعلن حق الشعب
الفلسطيني في تقرير المصير
وسنصبح التي
يمثلها وانا اريد ان انبه لشيء بسيط بسرعه
بسرعه كبيره لو سمحت فقط
اريد نعم اريد ان انبه واحذر ان الخطوه
التاليه ستقوم المجموعه الاوروبيه دفع
اسرائيل لانتخاب عضوا في هذه هذه من
التداعيات التي ربما سنناقشها الان بعد
فاصل قصير ارجو ان تبقوا
معنا اهلا من جديد الى هذه الحلقه التي
نناقش فيها انتخاب اسرائيل لمنصب نائب
رئيس اللجنه الامميه الرابعه المعنيه وهي
اللجنه المعينه وهي اللجنه السياسيه
المعنيه بعده قضايا في مقدمتها انهاء
الاستعمار دكتور فواز جرجس قبل الفاصل
كان عبد الحميد الصيام يتحدث عن طموح
اسرائيل اسرائيل تطمح ان تصل الى عضويه
مجلس الامن وفي الواقع الموقع الرسمي
للخارجيه الاسرائيليه يتحدث عن ان اسرائيل
في عام 2019 سترشح نفسها لهذه العضويه
ام هل فعلا ممكن ان يحدث هذا التاهيل ال
الذي تحدثت عنه ان تصل الامور الى هذه ال
درجه لا استبعد ذلك ابدا لا استبعد ذلك
ابدا ان حيث ان الدول الاوروبيه هذه الدول
التي تحترم حقوق الانسان هذه الدول التي
تشدد على اهميه انهاء الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
هي الدول التي الدول التي رشحت اسرائيل
لهذه العضويه ومن هنا نظريا لا استبعد ذلك
لدي اقتراح متواضع انا اتمنى من بعض الدول
العربيه وحلفاء الدول العربيه اداق الدول
العربيه واصدقاء الشعب الفلسطيني ان
يتقدموا باقتراح متواضع الى هذه اللجنه
بقضيه انهاء الحلقه الاخيره من الاستعمار
الاممي في منطقه العالم العربي هذا القرار
انا اتحدث بصراحه قرار جدي من قبل اصدقاء
وحلفاء الشعب الفلسطيني دوليا قرار جدي
ورسمي يقدم الى هذه اللجنه طالما اسرائيل
الان هي نائبه هذه اللجنه والهدف من هذا
القرار انهاء اخر حلقه في الاستعمار
الدولي وخاصه في في المنطقه العربيه في
فلسطين
ا يعني قد يكون هذا لا ادري مدى واقعيه
هذا الطرح هل يمكن فعلا دكتور مصطفى
البرغوثي ان نشهد سيناريو
كهذا هل ستلعب دور ربما في الدفع مثل هذا
السيناريو الى
الواجهه طبعا ممكن وفي شيء اهم لسه ممكن
اقترحه وضروري ان يطبق وحتى الان منظمه
التحرير متردده في اتخاذه ولكن يجب ان
تتخذه وخاصه بعد هذا ال الانتخاب الاخير
لاسرائيل
وخاصه بعد الاجتياحات التي يمارسها الان
نتنياهو ويكرر السيناريو الاجرامي لشارون
من قبل الان من واجب منظمه التحرير برايي
ان تستكمل خطواتها في الامم المتحده وان
تتوجه فورا الى محكمه الجنايات الدوليه ان
تنضم فلسطين الى محكمه الجنايات الدوليه
وتفتح عشرات الملفات لمحاكمه اسرائيل على
جرائم الحرب التي ترتكبها الان في الاراضي
المحتله بما فيها جريمه الاستعمار هذا هو
الرد الفعال والقوي والمؤثر الذي يمكن ان
يزلزل الارض من تحت اقدام الاسرائيليين
ويجعل قاده اسرائيل بما فيها قاده جيوشهم
وقادتهم السياسيين عاجزين عن الذهاب الى
اي مكان في العالم ربما سوى للولايات
المتحده ولكن السؤال الاهم ربما هل تجد ان
هل هناك ما يؤشر الى ان هناك استعداد من
الجانب الفلسطيني لاتخاذ مثل هذا القرار
القوي والشجاع كما
ذكرت للاسف هناك تردد ولكن انا ارى ان هذا
الامر سياتي في النهايه كامر حتمي لانه اي
محاوله لتجنب الصراع محكومه بالفشل اي
مراهنه على مفاوضات مع اسرائيل ليس فقط
فشلت في الماضي وانما ستفشل في المستقبل
لم يتركوا مجالا لمن يريد ان يفاوض اصلا
وبالتالي القضيه لا يوجد امام الشعب
الفلسطيني هو طريق واحد طريق الكفاح
والنضال لانهاء هذا الاحتلال وهذا النظام
العنصري لا يوجد امام الشعب الفلسطيني سوى
طريق واحد طريق المواجهه ونحن قلنا بالامس
انه اسرائيل ربما تظن انها بحملاتها
واجرام تكسر اراده الشعب الفلسطيني ولكن
هي تخطئ انها تجابه اليوم في هذه اللحظه
في شوارع الضفه الغربيه بحرا هائجا من
الشباب الثائر الذي على استعداد لتجديد
شباب الانتفاضه الفلسطينيه في وجه
الاحتلال والاستعمار لكن هناك نقطه مهمه
اخرى لابد من الاشاره لها وهو ان هناك
انفصام مريع ومؤذي ومخ
بين مواقف شعوب بعض الدول الاوروبيه
ومواقف حكوماتها وانا اعتقد ان حركه
التضامن ولجان المقاطعه وفرض العقوبات على
اسرائيل التي تحقق نجاحات كبيره في الفتره
الاخيره من واجبها وستنطلق انا متاكد ايضا
ستنطلق في محاسبه لهذه الحكومات وفي
برلمانات على مثل هذه الفضيحه المشينه
التي ارتكبت في الامم المتحده عبد الحميد
صيام هل فعلا يعني تعتقد ان لمثل هذه
الجهود لمثل هذه المقترحات تاثير حقيقي هل
يمكن ايقاف هذا التغلغل وهذا الغطاء الذي
بدات الامم المتحده تعطيه لاسرائيل بهذه
الطريقه
الصريحه
والواضح يعني من خلال خبرتي في الامم
المتحده وعملي الطويل داخل هذه المنظمه لم
ارى المنظمه منحازه بشكل وقح الى جانب
اسرائيل مثل هذه الاداره الان في الايام
القادمه عندما مثلا تم خطف الثلاث
مستوطنين اصدر الامين العام فورا بيانا
يدين ذلك وله الحق في ذلك مثلا ولكن كل ما
عملت اسرائيل بعد ذلك من اجتياح المدن
وهدم سبع بيوت واقتحام 700 بيت وقتل شاب
في مخيم الجلزون واقتحام جامعه بير زيت لم
ينطقوا بكلمه واحده وفي كل يوم اتحدث امام
الصحافه المعتمده واسال المتحدث الرسمي
لماذا لم يصدر الامين العام بيان ولا جواب
هنا هناك هذه اداره منحازه لذلك المجموعه
العربيه وهي للامانه ان المجموعه العربيه
بغض النظر عن خلافات الامه العربيه هناك
وخلافات قياداتها دائما تبقى متوازنه
متقاربه تقوم وتنسك خطواتها معا لذلك
عليها مسؤوليه ايضا في التحرك السريع مع
الدول لان انت لو تعرفين من هي هذه الدول
التي صوتت لاسرائيل هذه دول صغيره معظمها
لا توجد على مملكه طنجا وك باتسي وجزر
سليمان وجزر ومارشال الايلاند وهذه جزر
صغيره معظمها يعني تدور في فلك امريكا
وبعض الدول اللاتينيه وبعض الدول
الافريقيه لو كان هناك تحرك مع هذه الدول
واقامه علاقات سليمه مع هذه الدول لوجدت
اسرائيل نفسها معزوله في الماضي عندما كان
يتكلم وزير خارجيه اسرائيل في الجمعيه
العامه كان نصف الجمعيه العامه يخرجون من
القاعه الان بعض الدول العربيه عندما
يتحدث مندوب نقطه مهمه جدا دول عربيه يخرج
اذا يعني هذه دكتور فواز جرجس ربما اختم
معك يعني هل فعلا يمكن ان تقوم المجموعه
العربيه ه امامها الدور فعلا حتى لا تفاجا
باسرائيل عضو في مجلس الامن عام 2019
دعيني اكون صريحا انا لا لا اشك في نوايا
المجموعه العربيه ولكن دبلوماسيه المجموعه
العربيه مشتته غير مركزه غير منهجيه هذا
واقع ومن هنا غير قدرتها ليست لديها
القدره على التاثير في هذه القرارات
النقطه الاولى النقطه الثانيه اهم سلاح
لدى الشعوب العربيه لدى الشعب الفلسطيني
الان هو سلاح المؤسسات دوليه الشعب
الفلسطيني طبعا هناك اكثر من اذات يعني
نحن اذات المقاومه الشعب الفلسطيني ولكن
ايضا سلاح الشعب الفلسطيني تقرير بالذهاب
الى المؤسسات الدوليه محكمه الجنايات
الدوليه ومحاكمه اسرائيل و حكام
اسرائيليين الذين استخدموا العنف ضد الشعب
الفلسطيني الاعزل ه هذا سلاح خطير القياده
الاسرائيليه مرعوبه هذا سلاح نووي تتخوف
منه القياده الاسرائيليه القياده
الفلسطينيه مع الشعب الفلسطيني مطلوب منها
ان تتحرك وفورا بالاضافه الى عده الادوات
الاخيره لان طبعا الصراع ليس هو فقط ادات
واحده عده ادوات ولكن الدبلوماسيه العربيه
ناقصه غير فعاله في هذه اللحظه وانتخاب
اسرائيل هو دلاله على عدم مركزيه المجموعه
دبلوماسيه ا اكثر من نقطه اليوم يعني
اشرنا اليها تحدثنا عن ان الدول العربيه
تستطيع ان تتحرك باتجاه دول صغيره ان
تكسبها بحيث لا تصوت بهذه الطريقه في
المستقبل ايضا موضوع طبعا ذهاب فلسطين الى
محكمه الجنايات الدوليه المقترح الذي
ذكرته دكتور جرجس فيما يتعلق بمجموعه
حلفاء فلسطين او اصدقاء فلسطين بحيث
يتوجهون ومطالبه هذه اللجنه بانهاء
الاستعمار يعني نتمنى ان نتابع تداعيات
هذه الخطوه تداعيات ايجابيه من الطرف
العربي والفلسطيني في حلقات قادمه شكرا
جزيلا لضيوفي شكرا للدكتور فواز جرجس شكرا
للدكتور عبد الحميد الصيام من نيويورك
وشكرا للدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي من رام الله
وشكرا لكم مشاهدينا الكرام على متابعه هذه
الحلقه من برنامج م وراء
الخبر
ه